[Applauso]
periferie dell'anima mi ha detto ma
anche questo è scritto sul nel foyer del
nostro teatro
noi abbiamo una storia molto strana io
ho 64 anni a luglio 65 ne avevo 19
quando nasce l'elfo io complice questo
innamoramento occasionale con una
ragazza che è qui dopo 45 anni ancora
mia moglie mi metto a fare teatro mentre
la mia vita era tutt'altro ma noi siamo
un utopia vivente perché noi non
sognavamo di fare un gruppo teatrale noi
vogliamo fare un grande teatro stabile
però 19 anni un con utopia diciamo ma il
nostro modello di teatro era riuscire a
costruire un ensemble come quelli che ci
piacevano andavamo a berlino a vedere
lascia udine oppure andavamo a parigi a
vedere il teatro soleil e noi vogliamo
costruire una realtà come quella quando
si ha 19 anni 20 anni 21 anni si è molto
liberi di sognare ma ci si può anche
molto illudere ma noi siamo stati molto
determinati e abbiamo fatto una scelta
fondamentale nella nostra vita è una
scelta che ci ha reso in un certo senso
più difficile il cammino
noi abbiamo scelto di viaggiare come
spesso si sente parlare di ubuntu no
questa questa forma africana di dea
della vita io sono perchè ci sono gli
altri oppure si può anche dire se vuoi
andare veloce vai da solo se vuoi andare
in gruppo vai lontano e noi abbiamo
deciso
molti dei dei nostri soci da cristina a
fernando bruni aida marinelli a luca
toracca corinna agustoni sono ancora con
noi dopo 45 anni perché abbiamo deciso
di viaggiare attraversare questa città
in gruppo non era molto di moda perché
eravamo continuamente spinti a venire
via dal gruppo come per esempio ha fatto
capire salvatores diventando un
importantissimo regista dc ma vincendo
anche un oscar ma continuamente
stimolati a fare una carriera
individuale ma quello che noi vogliamo
fare era cambiare il teatro italiano
portare dramaturgia italiana
contemporanea in in milano e in tutta in
tutta
italia e continuare a farlo da artisti
indipendenti
anche lì i teatri pubblici grandi teatri
stabili hanno tutti i teatri pubblici
non erano teatri indipendenti come il
nostro bene ci siamo riusciti siamo
riusciti nel 2000 nel 2010 addirittura a
realizzare il più grande dei nostri
sogni
un teatro in corso buenos aires con tre
sale progettato completamente da noi e
questo è era assolutamente impensabile
condanno 19 20 anni e adesso è una cosa
concreta che accade ma perché tutto
questo perché volevamo anche e qui vi
leggo una cosa che ho scritto di recente
perché è molto chiara e penso che che tu
l'abbia vista quando si realizza lo
spettacolo di otello proprio scritta
perché volevo definire con parole esatte
il tipo di il tipo di teatro che noi
sogniamo noi sogniamo un teatro il
teatro che ci sta a cuore si fonda su un
principio di piacere di sensualità e su
un contrasto continuo tra leggerezza e
struggimento per questo abbiamo dedicato
le tre sale del teatro a shakespeare a
fassbinder e appena bauch che hanno
saputo dar corpo in modi diversi a
questa ricerca di piacere ho continuato
a interrogarmi per tutta la vita sul
piacere che mi ha dato tutto il teatro
che ho visto e che ho fatto quando il
teatro è vivo quando è fatto ai suoi
massimi livelli
o anche quando è aurorale creato da
giovanissimi ma in ogni caso se quando
quello che accade in scena è teatro
ecco che la mente accelera le sue
emozioni acquista una profondità che
provi solo nei momenti più intensi della
tua esistenza emozioni riflessioni tutto
assieme emozioni e riflessioni
il groppo in gola del senso della vita e
della sensazione di essere vivi
la risposta che mi sono dato è questa il
piacere che ricerche che voglio produrre
con il mio teatro è il piacere di bere
la vita gran sorsi come accade ma rare
volte nella vita reale sono i momenti
che più contano
il grande teatro ci mette a confronto
con la magnifica ma sempre vulnerata
grandezza della vita umana con la nostra
umana capacita di immaginare e produrre
qualcosa di immortale
attraverso le nostre fragilissime e
brevissime vite di essere più che
mortali e otello per esempio ne è un
esempio di questa di questa
realizzazione un teatro così un teatro
così è fatto per essere noi strumento di
mediazione fra gli autori e il pubblico
enel tra è in questo rapporto grotowski
nel 70 definito il teatro in quello che
accade tra l'attore e lo spettatore
e se un teatro è fatto soltanto per qua
soltanto per l'arte come se fosse una
cosa separata di stato non accade e se
il teatro è fatto soltanto per lì certo
che c'è è forma di intrattenimento e
fatto solo per voi e non per l'arte e
noi quello che sognavamo e che anche lo
slogan del piccolo teatro di milano un
teatro d'arte per tutti cioè vide
ricoltivare al massimo quella quella
forma che dicevo questo teatro che
smuove pensiero ed emozione al tempo ma
che la massima arte ma per tutti cioè un
teatro aperto e adesso che siamo entrati
in quello spazio aperto non soltanto a
pubblici a generazioni diverse ma anche
a gruppi altre realtà che come noi lo
vogliono praticare e qui a milano devo
dire c'è una quantità impressionante di
giovani compagnie che seguono la nostra
strada che hanno qualche cosa da dire è
che hanno questo meccanismo di rapporto
emotivo con quello che vogliono
raccontare ma sono in grado di
raccontare storie anche molto importanti
volevo aggiungere una cosa noi abbiamo
chiamato una sala shakespeare perché
shakespeare è stato l'inventore del
montaggio cinematografico prima che
esistesse il cinema c'è stato un grande
rivoluzionario se voi pensate a
shakespeare come un classico commette un
grosso errore lo mettete in una bacheca
e loro entrate da voi shakespeare è un
autore incandescente e metterle cina
oggi significa riportare
all'incandescenza originaria il lavoro
di questo grande artista e non farne un
monumento che ci isola da questa
esperienza e shakespeare è molto
interessante anche perché a proposito di
pregiudizi a proposito di riforme di
pensiero shakespeare viveva in un mondo
dove c'erano un sacco di pregiudizi il
suo pubblico era un pubblico misogino
era un pubblico razzista era un pubblico
non accennava a contrastare
ideologicamente dal punto di vista
opposto i pregiudizi del pubblico
shakespeare li metteva addirittura in
scena in otello chicago che tutto la
misoginia possibile immaginabile il
moralismo lo mette in scena quasi quasi
è successo con il pubblico perché è
molto molto contagioso no anche chi chi
e sono molto i pregiudizi sono anche
molto facile per avere consenso al bar o
nel caso di otello nel caso di tante
persone come lui di di raccogliere
consenso e shakespeare però smonta pian
piano al contrario perché fa parlare tre
donne perché mostra nella vicenda del
percorso e le due musiche in shakespeare
sono molto importanti perché siete voi
alla fine questo anche una lezione per
la politica si deve alla fine che dovete
scegliere con la vostra esperienza di
vita ex vi lascia lì un finale in cui
alla fine le somme letti dal pubblico è
sempre questo il grande miracolo di
shakespeare e adesso che ho parlato di
un po di storia dell'elfo questa nostra
idea di gruppo come utopia per superare
anche questa idea che i giovani come
eravamo noi allora dovessero starsi
nella periferia al teatro quartiere alle
un cavallo al centro sociale isole
eccetera invece noi volevamo costruire
qualcosa che fosse al centro
dell'esperienza cittadina e fosse
autonoma indipendente
adesso parliamo invece di un particolare
spettacolo e di come l'arte può
veramente svolgere una funzione di
pensiero completamente diverso da da da
altri ma che può anticipare e spiegare
certe cose che si sviluppano nel tempo
come cambia il mondo
noi abbiamo fatto anni fa e mai stato
scritto nel 93 angels in america
io vi voglio far vedere tre minuti di
immagini due minuti ma è poco più di
immagini di angels in america perché c'è
un discorso che mi interessa molto farvi
negli ultimi tre minuti che mi
resteranno di questa ted prego e nel
momento in cui la razza umana cominciò a
progredire a viaggiare a mescolarsi
ogni cosa cominciò a scollarsi dapprima
il fenomeno si manifestò sotto forma di
tremori in paradiso il paradiso è una
città molto simile a san francisco
così il progresso una migrazione scienza
movimento in avanti scuote l'universo il
paradiso stesso trema e si divide
progresso movimento scuotono lo invio e
degli cominciano ad abbandonarci stanco
dei suoi angeli stregato dall'umanità il
mortificante imitazione di voi la sua
creazione minore
egli si mise in viaggio senza saper per
dove poi il 18 aprile 1906 in quel
giorno
girando terremoto di san francisco quel
giorno il 18 aprile 1906 il nostro padre
amante dai milioni di indicibili nomi il
sacro segno della dal cuore tutti i
mondi discendono il dio dell'universo se
ne andò tagliola corta e non fece più
ritorno
dove
sia andato non lo sappiamo può essere
che si mai più non torni e amareggiata
respinti
noi aspettiamo confusi taglia la corda
sì mi ricorda qualcuno l'uomo che se ne
andò si è successo anche a me con lewis
anche adesso se lui dovesse tornare io
l'ho riuso nella retta alla tua amica è
arrivato il momento di lasciarlo andare
per la sua strada o ma non è questo
quello che pensano gli angeli gli angeli
pensano che sia andato tutto troppo
oltre che in qualche modo dovremmo
fermarci tornare indietro non è così che
funziona il mondo prior e il mondo gira
solo in avanti avanti verso cosa devi
smetterla
smetterla di muovermi abbandona la
strada aperta non mescolando non
accoppiarsi con altre razze e lascia che
prestano ha radici profonde
se non di mischierà principali affermare
il congresso
ecco angels in america di tony kushner
avete visto non mescolatevi non migrate
questa profezia della stasi
ci siamo arrivati quello che sta
succedendo anche nel nostro paese è che
la paura del progresso del mutamento del
mescolamento delle razze la paura anche
in questo senso una paura positiva
quella di sprecare le risorse del paese
in modo che non siano più recuperabili
quello spettacolo celanti cell
anticipava in maniera paradossale
barocca ma in maniera molto visibile
ci siamo dentro in pieno il teatro
spesso fa così tony kushner ha costruito
questa storia che ha una storia di aids
una storia di relazioni fra vari e
diversi omosessuali ebrei cristiani
mormoni un meltin pot molto americano ma
è una storia che ci riguarda tutti e
dentro c'era questa profezia della stasi
dell'angelo che è un desiderio che molte
persone hanno che la soluzione per il
mondo si sa che il mondo si fermi che il
mondo il mondo non progredisca non vada
avanti e ma impossibile c'è una parte
positiva di questa idea della stasi che
quello riguarda le sacrosante risorse
del paese del dl del pianeta da
preservare
ma dall'altra parte cercare di fermare
la storia il movimento il progresso è
una è una è una a un certo punto quel
d'amico nero di prior del protagonista
dice ma questo angelo è un reazionario
cosmico
ecco siamo adesso nell'epoca in cui
questo scontro è molto e molto
importante questo scontro fra appunto il
desiderio che qualcuno sa che il mondo
si fermi perché altrimenti e ci si
rimette a costruire muri confini
eccetera e chi invece pensa che il mondo
debba accettare il cambiamento che è
difficile che è complicato
c'è soprattutto il problema di
distribuzione più equa delle risorse fra
le persone perché il mondo si spartisce
sempre di più fra una piccola parte di
chi ha una grande parte di persone che
sono escluse da questa ricchezza però
non è il chiudersi il l'idea
fondamentale non trasformare in in
fortezza e barricate le nostre nazioni
ma a tenerle aperte e noi riprenderemo
questo spettacolo perché alla forma
migliore per raccontare nell'epoca
contemporanea come il nostro percorso di
vita e lì c'è un personaggio tra l'altro
che lo rappresenta molto bene
molto spesso a qualche anticipazione
nella storia degli stati uniti
e qualche volta invece siamo noi che
l'abbiamo anticipata incitava prima il
libro essere willy l'oman essere roy con
richard nixon willy l'oman and mister
berlusconi
in fondo il personaggio di trump è un
personaggio che noi abbiamo anticipato
nel nostro paese perché il risultato del
processo che ha portato noi a essere a
essere quello che siamo e stato avere un
pò anticipato quello che l'america
adesso sta sperimentando il tycoon lassù
ma io facevo il personaggio di roy cohn
e ha avuto la grande soddisfazione che
circa un anno fa
trump ha detto where is my lai con voi
non sapete chi ero e commerce con è
stato il mentore di trump è stato colui
che gli ha insegnato che il modo per
vincere oggi in politica è aggredire
colpire non chiedere mai scusa e in
questo modo il mondo si tratta si sta
trasformando in una misura molto
negativa credo che il teatro in italia
sia un antidoto molto importante per
resistere a quello che sta succedendo
grazie
[Applauso]